Okay. So,
um trying to understand from like coming
from a Protestant background. So, like I
was under the impression that okay, so
in the Old Testament you do they do the
blood sacrifices day and night for the
atonement of their sins and then Christ
went to the cross for the last and final
atonement for sin. And if I put my faith
in him and make him the Lord of my life
and believe in him, I get to partake in
that atonement. Is that what the
Catholic faith teaches and believes or
do they have a different perspective or
>> this atonement?
>> Um, once I put my my faith in him and
believe in him, the atonement now covers
me. Is that's under my impression.
What does it mean to believe in him?
>> Um to acknowledge that he is God and
that I am going to follow his commands.
>> You just said believing in him means to
obey him, right? Because even the demons
know Jesus is God.
>> Correct.
>> And where do they go?
>> Uh hell.
>> But wait, they know he's God.
>> Yeah, that's correct. But there's two
parts to it.
>> Exactly. The other part is obeying him
which shows that you do love him and and
believe in him because believing in him
is trusting in him. Trusting in him is
to obey him. Right?
>> That is correct.
>> But one of the things he says if you
love me you'll obey me. He says you have
to be eating his flesh and drinking his
blood.
>> So how do you do that?
>> Um to my knowledge through the the Holy
Eucharist.
>> Well see now you're a Catholic then
you're not Protestant are you? Because
here here is what Jesus says. How do you
share in his atonement right here? I
gave you I'm not you don't need to know
Greek because I'm not a Greek scholar
and I don't pretend to be and I don't
care to be a scholar really. I know
there are people want to be scholars. I
don't care to be a scholar. I don't want
to be recognized as a scholar anyway.
You know, I don't want human accolades.
I want Jesus to love me and forgive me
and purify me and I trust in his grace.
So, one thing you're going to note if
you I just sent you the link. If you go
here, it says
The on makes it what they call and I'm
not trying to impress you. I'm just
trying to show you. It's a pre it's a
present participle active meaning it's
an ongoing action.
>> A present mean ongoing action. That's
why I notice it says the one eating.
>> It's ongoing, right?
Yes.
>> So, how do you how do you continue eat
of Jesus's flesh?
How are you continuing drinking? So
notice the on penon
>> you see it says drinking and the one
drinking of me
>> present active particle means it's an
ongoing action.
>> Gotcha.
>> So how do you continually eat and drink
eat the flesh and drink the blood of
Christ? Well obviously doing what he
tells you to do. But if we take the
flesh and blood of Christ, not simply
metaphorical, that we metaphorically
gnaw on him, but there's a sense in
which we need to actually physically eat
the flesh and drink the blood of Christ.
Well, that's the miracle of the
Eucharist.
And so what he procured on the cross,
your eternal redemption and the
forgiveness of all sins done after
baptism is yours when you partake of his
flesh
and drink of his blood. Because he says,
"If you're doing this, then you will
have the life of the age to come and
then he will resurrect you in the last
day and make you immortal." It's right
there. Right.
>> Okay. Yeah. I don't know. I've read all
of the the New Testament and I guess I
never read it this way or understood it
this way as I'm seeing it as you're
presenting it.
>> Yeah. Because everyone
inherits a set of traditions,
assumptions
due to their background. And those
assumptions and traditions will affect
how you see reality. So if you had
remained a Muslim, you would be reading
the Bible in light of Muslim lenses and
you'd be telling me it doesn't mean this
and the paracletus is Muhammad. Right?
Because no one enters the world
without being impacted affected by their
parents, by their relatives, by their
culture, by their background, by their
traditions. Right? So you enter the
world
and then you have your parents, your
family members, your ethnic group, your
religious tradition
hammering you, being indoctrinated by
it. So that no matter what you do, no
matter what you see, no matter what you
read, you now have these traditions
given to you by others which you filter
the way you see the world. Right.
>> Yep. That's right.
>> So, what I'm trying to get at is
depending on what tradition you've
inherited or what tradition you believe,
it will affect impact how you read these
statements.
>> Yeah, that's right.
>> Historically, Christians have always
taught this is a fact that in the
Eucharist, Christ is giving to us his
flesh and blood, his physical flesh and
blood you in the Eucharist
sacramentally,
right? So that when we feed off of the
Eucharist, we are feeding off the flesh
and blood of Christ because his life
becomes our life. And I'll explain that.
I'll expound that in a minute. But I
want to add to you the other part of
that verse because that was John 6 54.
But I want you to see what he says in
55.
Okay? So we're going to read it right
here.
John 653:55. Jesus therefore said to
them, "Most certainly I tell you, unless
you eat the flesh of the Son of Man and
drink his blood, you don't have life in
yourselves. He who eats my flesh and
drinks my blood has eternal life, and
I'll raise him up at the last day. For
my flesh is food indeed, and my blood is
drinked." The word there, real means
true. Not that the food you eat is fake.
But the food you eat only sustains your
physical body. and for a short period of
time. In fact, the food you eat came and
poison your body and shorten your
lifespan. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> So, this food you're eating is a shadow
of the true food because the flesh of
Christ and the blood of Christ gives you
real life. Remember when Jesus said,
"Enter life."
>> Mame.
>> So, what's the real life? The life to
come, right? The of the age to come.
>> Yep.
>> All right. So how then do you obtain
that? By the grace of the Lord Jesus
Christ. But just like you need food to
sustain this physical body as it dies,
you need the food of the age to come to
sustain you forever. What food sustains
you forever for the life to come?
>> Uh the holy eucharist right now. Well,
that's what it is because he says the
flesh of meat
true
food mean this is true food. This is
real food. The food you eat is a shadow
and that can only give you
temporary nourishment because you're
going to still die. But this is the real
true food that will sustain you forever.
Right. True. See
Can I ask a a quick question?
>> Yes.
>> So, is is there any correlation or
does it have to do anything like
whenever um Jesus told the disciples um
I have food that you don't know anything
of?
That's differently meaning that his
entire existence and purpose in coming
to the world is to fulfill the will of
the father. That's John 4:31-34. That's
in a different context as he's talking
about that the real food
that God has given him is to fulfill the
will of the father. Nothing else
matters.
>> Okay?
>> But this it connects with this here
earlier. Let me show you connects with
this earlier right here.
>> John 6 27:36. Here it is what I just
read to you in John 653 to 55.
right
>> is an expansion elaboration what he said
earlier John 6 27:36 don't work for the
food which perishes see why I said the
food you eat
sustains you metabolically but even then
temporarily because you're going to die
anyway
>> so don't work for the food which
perishes but for the food which remains
to eternal life which the son of man
will give you for God the father has
sealed him they said therefore to What
must we do that we may may work the
works of God? What kind of work does God
require us to do to have this food that
will give us incorruptible everlasting
life? Jesus answered them, "This is the
work of God that you believe in him."
And the the tense is that you are
believing in him ongoing belief when he
has sent.
>> They said, "Therefore to him, what then
do you do for a sign that we may see and
believe you? What work do you do? Our
fathers ate the mana in the wilderness.
As it is written, he gave them bread out
of hemp teeth. So God gave us a sign
during time Moses, he reigned bread from
heaven.
What sign do you give to show us that
you are speaking from God? Jesus
therefore said to them, most certainly I
tell you, it wasn't Moses who gave you
the bread out of heaven, but my father
gives you the true bread out of heaven.
Notice that word true again.
>> My flesh is true food and my blood is
true. Mhm.
>> drink.
>> Mhm.
>> Here's that word again. True bread out
of heaven. For the bread of God is that
which comes down out of heaven and gives
life to the world.
They said therefore to him, Lord, always
give us this bread. See, always be
giving us this bread that will give us
the life of the age to come, never
ending, incorruptible
life. Jesus said to them, I am the bread
of life.
Whoever comes to me will not be hungry.
Whoever believes in me will never be
thirsty. But I told you have seen me and
yet you don't believe. All right. Now,
here's my question.
Here's my question.
The mana that they ate, did they
actually eat it physically? Was it
actual substantial bread that they ate?
>> I thought it was.
>> You thought it was? It's almost like
you're doubting. So, what did they eat?
Phantom bread.
What were they eating seven days a week?
Phantom bread or was it bread that they
ate?
>> I would say real bread.
>> You keep saying I would say it's almost
like you're doubting.
Did they eat actual bread in the desert?
>> Yes.
>> Exactly. Because when you say I said,
you know, it's like, wait, what was it?
Of course it's bread. Just like they ate
real quails and they drank real water,
right?
>> Yeah. So if Jesus says the mana is a
picture, a foreshadowing of the true
bread that comes down from heaven and
they ate that bread physically, then how
do you eat Jesus physically?
>> With the Holy Eucharist.
>> There you go.
>> So that's
>> Go ahead. Go ahead.
So like being somebody who can receive
the atonement that was made by Jesus
Christ uh in the Catholic faith, it's
you believe in in him and obey him and
partake in the holy Eucharist.
>> That's how you share in his atoning
sacrifice because it's not just a
sacrifice to pay the debt of sin. It's a
sacrifice that you must partake of and
eat because even the priests, they would
end up eating some of the sacrificial
meat, right, that was offered.
>> Correct.
>> So then
it's not just the Catholic Church, by
the way, because this is where it's
going to broaden your perspective.
>> This has been the teaching of the church
from as far back as you can trace it.
Meaning from the beginning. But less
people want to say, well, yeah, but the
gospels, you interpret that
metaphorically. Well, the earliest
Christians, the closest to the apostles,
their very heirs and successors, didn't
interpret it metaphorically. They took
the Eucharist as becoming the actual
flesh and blood of Christ. This is
unanimous. Proof of it is this. You
focus on the Catholics as if they're the
only ones. Are you aware that right now
in my chat in my live stream there are
oriental Orthodox meaning those who
would be Coptic or Syriak Orthodox,
Eastern Orthodox, Syrian Church and
Catholics, and they all agree the
Eucharist becomes the flesh and blood of
Christ.
Now, why is that?
>> Go ahead.
>> Oh, I was going to say I didn't I didn't
know if that's what the Orthodox Church
also believed as well. better believe
they do. There is no ancient church that
goes back to the apostles that denies
the Eucharist as the actual flesh and
blood of Christ.
>> None.
>> None. Not a zip. In fact, they're in my
comment section. In fact, there is no
ancient church that goes back to the
time of the apostles that do not make
the center of their worship, the
Eucharist. All of them are liturggical
churches. All of them celebrate the mass
and the eukarist daily and on Sunday
part in particular.
>> How do you explain this commonality
amongst these churches that are in
schism and not in full communion?
>> Well, that that's the way it had to have
been from the beginning. And so
regardless of where things have
diverged,
>> it was there in the beginning.
>> Yes. In fact, oriental orthox there,
some of them are my mods. They're
listening right now. there in the
comment section. If you if someone tells
you I'm a Coptic Christian, he's pretty
much an oriental Orthodox. Oriental
Orthodox
have a different understanding of how
Christ is one person with two natures.
They believe he's truly God, truly
human, but they don't speak of two
natures. They speak of one composite
nature, but they believe the same thing.
Christ is truly God, truly human. Okay?
>> Say here, you got orient to Orthodox
comedy.
They broke off from what we now call
Eastern Orthodox and the Catholic Church
in the 400s.
So here confirmed uh here so they know
I'm not lying. 400s that's like fifth
century the Assyrian church. We have
people here who are from the Assyrian
church. Church of my ancestors church I
was baptized in. They were ostracized
broken off in the 400s. Now remember
this 400 years after Christ and that's
what over 1500 years right?
Yeah.
>> Now I'm going to ask them oriental
Orthodox in church. Do any of you deny
that when the prayer is offered, the
Holy Spirit takes the bread and the wine
and makes the bread and wine the actual
flesh, body, and blood of Christ. Watch.
Watch the comment section.
You're going to see. And they're not
Catholic and they're not Eastern
Orthodox. They're in schism. You're
going to see it right here. when you see
them because it takes a 15-second delay.
See, no one denies it. See,
do you deny that? Do you deny that it
becomes the flesh, blood, body of our
Lord and Savior Jesus Christ? See?
>> See?
So, how do you account for the fact that
churches,
all right, churches
that have been in schism, they're not in
communion since the fifth century, four
years after Christ.
Till this day, they all have liturgy.
Till this day, they all celebrate the
Eucharist as the centerpiece, the focus
of liturgy, and they all believe it
becomes the flesh and blood of Christ.
Where do they get that from?
Well, it had been the original practice.
>> You got it.
See here.
You see?
>> Yep.
>> Even in even on my rumble, Jaden, I'm
oriental as well. No, we all believe
that it's the actual flesh and blood of
Christ. So then let's compare that to
the Protestants.
If I ask an Anglican and a Lutheran, do
you believe that the Eucharist is simply
bread and wine or do you believe it's
also the flesh and blood of Christ? Now,
they may understand
the reality of how it is the flesh and
blood of Christ differently, but they'll
say, "No, Lutheran say no, it's the
flesh and blood of Christ and
Anglicans." But then I bring in the
Baptist, then I bring in evangelicals
and they say, "No, it's symbolic." So do
you understand that the ancient
churches, the ancient churches that go
back to the time of the apostles
historically who've been in schism, no
one denies what the Eucharist is. But in
your Protestantism, you can't even
agree.
So if I take you to Lutheran, don't take
my word for it. Go to Lutheran church.
Do you think the bread and wine they're
symbolic? No. They are the flesh and
blood of Christ. Now they would call it
consubstantiation. It's joined to What
about Anglicans? They're simply a
Protestant version Catholic Church. No,
it's the flesh and blood of Christ. I
asked the Baptist, "No, it's symbolic."
And they'll give you cracker and grape
juice. Is that how they celebrated it?
>> Yeah, they that's the Baptist churches I
went to. That's what they did. And the
>> non-denominational evangelical churches.
So how do you explain churches that have
been schism
ostracized and one another since the
400s they have the same type of worship
liturgy
mass the Eucharist as the centerpiece of
their worship everyone else around
taking Jesus in the Eucharist taking his
flesh and blood literally physically in
the Eucharist and their worship is
virtually identical. You have the
bishops. You have the priests, the
deacons west
wearing priestly garb chanting prayers,
hymns and praises to God. Why is it
identical? But you can't get that in
Protestantism.
>> I'm not sure. Doesn't make any sense. It
doesn't make sense
as a Christian.
It tells you that this practice of
liturgy where the whole liturggical
service is focused on the Eucharist must
go back to the apostles in order to
account for the fact that these churches
that have been in schism broken up since
the fifth century all observe it till
this day. That means these practices
were already in place before the schism.
Yeah.
>> It had to have been something
universally observed before the 400s.
>> Yeah.
>> So who's wrong? the churches who've been
doing it long before there was a Martin
and even Martin Luther Luther said to
Yulri Zwingley because Yulri Zwingley
said no the bread and the cup represent
the body and blood of Christ and Martin
Luther said it says it is my body and we
don't allegorize it. Martin Luther is
adamant that it is the flesh blood of
Christ. But his fellow magisterial
reformer says no it's not. It's
symbolic.
So you see if I bring you Protestants
and I ask them here I'm going to this is
an and I don't want you to take my word
for it. Do this. Bring someone who's
Church of Christ. I'm just going to
mention four denominations. Church of
Christ,
Baptists, Lutheran, Anglicans, these
four, that's it. Among the many,
if I ask these four, does water baptism
save you? Three of them will say yes.
One of them will say no. Lutheran,
Anglicans, Church of Christ will say
yes. The Baptists will say no. It's
symbolic. All right. If I ask, do you
baptize infants? Two of them will say
yes. Lutheran and Anglicans. The the
other two will say no. Church of Christ
and the Baptists.
>> Do you believe the Eucharist is the
flesh and blood of Christ? Two of them
will say yes. The other two will say no.
>> What's going on here? And that's just
these issues. So, does baptism save?
Three of the four will say yes. Do you
baptize infants? Three of the four will
say, I'm sorry. Two of the four will say
yes. Okay. The Eucharist, the flesh and
blood of Christ, two of the four will
say yes. And if I bring in the
Presbyterians, does baptism save you?
No. But do you baptize infants? Yes.
But if I bring you oriental Orthodox,
it's right here. They're here. If I
bring you Catholics and I bring you
Eastern Orthodox Church, do you baptize
infants? Yes. Does water baptism save
you? Yes. Is the Eucharist the flesh and
blood of Christ? Yes.